they know the rest of the donbass is
next on the russian target list
we're the first british journalist to
get a look at the foreign supplied heavy
artillery they hope will turn the war
for them
and they remain optimistic despite their
recent losses with this message to the
russians
it's not for long the commander says
we'll kick you out and get it all back
the loss of one half of the donbass is
tough but they're not giving up they
can't
this heavy artillery system is highly
accurate and highly mobile they've been
provided to ukraine by multiple
countries this one's a caesar and it
comes from france but they are still
heavily outnumbered and outgunned by
russian stocks and that's why they're
crying out for many more
the russians are already pushing deeper
into eastern ukraine
this is the ukrainian's most effective
way of fighting back
the donbass battlefield has seen the
most intense fighting of the year so far
since the russian leader unilaterally
declared the two regions independent
but russia wants all of the donbass and
it doesn't look like much is going to
stop them
this is what a howitzer can do here it
obliterates a russian tank but this
modern weaponry's arrived late and maybe
not in enough time to save the donbass
there's an awful repetition about this
slow grinding and brutal war
aids unloaded for the residents of
krasnojriska on the front line of
russia's territorial ambitions in
ukraine for eight years
they have about 6 000 names of people
who desperately need help
the residents feel caught in the middle
of this land grab and attacked by both
sides
um
to drive around donetsk is to take your
life in your hands every time
the road is pitted with craters
he's pointing at a cluster bomb left in
a field of wheat
so one shell landed there
and it blew out all the windows here the
one hospital here has been hit several
times it's barely functioning with most
medics too scared to work here
there are shell craters dotted all
around
and again a distant sound of more
artillery fire
olga is immediately on edge
how often does this happen
yeah
she insists we all go inside the
hospital for safety
the boarded up windows inside offer slim
protection against the power of a shell
or an air strike it's an international
war crime to deliberately target
civilians or medical facilities
we travel even closer to the russian
line and mourinho town which has changed
hands a couple of times already and
where the russians are intensifying
their attacks now
here they say the russians are using all
types of artillery all types of missile
and we were shown parts of what the
police say were air bombs used for
firing phosphorus phosphorus again the
russian tactics are terrifyingly
familiar hit destroy then advance
we're trying to keep to the tree line
because they're pretty convinced that
there are a lot of saboteurs russian
saboteurs operating in this area who are
acting as spotters for the attacks and
the attacks have been pretty extensive
so again the residents have gone
underground there are more than 20
people living in this one old people and
mothers with teenagers
how much longer do you think you can
carry on like this
as long as possible she says we're
afraid to go back home because there's
nowhere to hide there
the fighting has left schools shattered
and there seems to be a deliberate low
targeting here right through a shelter
where families were taking cover nothing
seems off limits in this war
alex crawford sky news in the donetsk
region of the donbass